what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and a lot is happening in the Marvel
world right now a lot that is very very
exciting specifically in regards to some
of the Defenders returning reprising
some of their roles and making their way
over to the MCU if you haven't heard
recently John berthal is returning as
The Punisher he is now officially going
to be in the MCU right now reportedly
for Daredevil born again and since this
news recently came out a lot of people
have been asking well what does this
mean for other characters like Luke Cage
could Luke Cage Iron Fist and other
characters be coming to the MCU as well
well we do have a little bit of an
update about that today meanwhile some
characters are getting recast and
apparently there is a pretty simple
reason as to why that is also a little
bit of news about the Marvels they
showed some test screenings for the
movie apparently and there's a lot of
confusing talk going around about this
online right now but we're gonna clear
it up all for you in video and to top it
all off we have some news about
Spider-Man across the spider-verse new
details have been revealed by Empire
magazine and I gotta say I really love
what they're doing with this film first
let's dive into the Marvels because a
lot of people seem to be talking about
this online this started yesterday when
Jeff Snyder was on the hot Mike podcast
and he stated this the Marvels is a show
with Brie Larson clashing with teona
Paris behind the scenes says Brie Larson
was hard to work with and is angry that
the movie is titled the Marvels and not
Captain Marvel 2. Now apparently this is
something that he heard not something
that he witnessed firsthand but it got a
lot of people talking because Brie
Larson has gotten some Flack over the
years both because of her portrayal of
Captain Marvel and how she acted off
screen as well however multiple insiders
online have spoken up about this after
this statement The Watcher being one of
them stating that report about Brie
Larson being difficult on the set of the
marbles is absolute false she was
looking forward to the sequel being a
team up then the account great face
stated he is lying this not getting
along is something that cannot be either
right or wrong like casting information
he didn't write an article about it he
made up fake drama about an actress to
get attention and then The Insider KC
Walsh came and said again I've heard
nothing negative around this production
the movie has gotten more positive
praise from test than other MCU films
this year and this is very interesting
because it's not the first time that
we've heard that the Marvels has tested
well now it is worth noting that
somebody did ask Casey Walsh if it was
better than Guardians of the Galaxy 3
and he replied no but that's a really
good sign because that means that both
the Marvels and Guardians of the Galaxy
3 should both be pretty good movies and
with fans complaining a decent amount
about Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
this should come as some pretty great
news to those and both Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 and the Marvels are going
to be pretty big movies the Guardians
volume 3 because they are introducing
the high evolutionary and it's the end
of the Guardians of the Galaxy current
team as we know it I'm sure a new team
will be formed and continue to go on but
it's pretty clear at this point that
some Guardians are going to die and some
might retire and move on meanwhile the
Marvels is supposed to go against a big
Cosmic threat and hopefully they explain
the connection that Kamala Khan's Bengal
has to Kang the Conqueror recently
during a lot of interviews for Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania Jeff lovnes has
said that you can expect Kang to show up
before the Kang Dynasty once again
obviously in Loki 2 but in other
projects as well so perhaps he makes a
cameo in the Marvels either way whatever
is happening with the Marvels it does
sound like the movie is on track and is
going to be a pretty good movie it
doesn't sound like there is really much
drama happening and you know how it can
be sometimes when messages get relayed
to one person than another than another
the message kind of gets lost by the
time it gets to the end person but now
on to some Daredevil news production has
begun for Daredevil born again we have
plenty of set photos of Hell's Kitchen
everything is about to be really
underway like I mentioned the Punisher
is returning John Bernthal will reprise
his role and now be in the MCU and it's
also reported that Kristen Ritter is
going to be returning to play Jessica
Jones and there was a rumor going around
for a while that in Echo the echo series
Daredevil was going to be searching for
Jessica Jones however we haven't really
heard at this point in time which show
Jessica Jones might appear in however
several insiders including the account
film Odyssey have confirmed that she is
coming back plus not to mention Kristen
Ritter posted a picture on Instagram of
her getting back at it at the gym
wearing a daredevil shirt seemingly
hinting at her return the only question
now is when now we do have some
recasting news and this kind of goes
along with the question that a lot of
people have been asking like will Luke
Cage return will Iron Fist return Etc
well according to a report yesterday
from The Hollywood Reporter Marvel
Studios has cast Sandrine Holt to play
Vanessa Fisk in the upcoming Daredevil
Born Again series officially recasting
the actress for the role the wife of
Kingpin Wilson Fisk now like I mentioned
apparently there is a pretty simple
explanation for this The Watcher stated
this on Twitter Vanessa's recasting is
due to scheduling conflicts same
character different actress no need or
conspiracy theories she is still married
to Fisk as seen in season 3 of Daredevil
she will also not be the only one that
gets recast one again is going to be a
long shoot and some of the Netflix
Marvel actors have simply moved on so
it's not that Marvel Studios doesn't
necessarily want all of the original
actors back it's that some of them have
moved on with their lives or some of
them are still acting as a profession
which is what they do and they simply
are in conflict with their schedules to
where Unfortunately they won't be able
to return to play the actors that they
once played in the Netflix series so for
those asking what does this mean for
Luke Cage Iron Fist all of the other
ones that you want to see return the
answer is yes it is entirely possible
for those characters to appear in the
MCU and their original actors to return
to reprise those roles at this point in
time it would kind of depend on whether
or not the actors were available to do
so and of course if Marvel Studios
wanted those characters to appear in the
MCU however so far we have already a few
members of the defenders in the MCU and
it would make sense that Kevin feige
would maybe want an entire defender's
reunion to take place in the MCU so
let's hope that is the case and let's
hope the actors are available to return
now let's top this off with some great
news about Spider-Man across the
spider-verse film that many fans
including myself are really excited for
and it really is going to be a big
spider-verse film and a recent article
by Empire gives us a little bit more
insight about the movie that makes us
even more excited in the interview with
Empire Christopher Miller who was a
writer and producer for across the
spider-verse Tells Empire our contract
with the audience is to bring them
something they've never seen before the
first film was about bringing characters
into miles's Dimension this is about
miles heading off into others each world
is a robust Place we've essentially made
five films in one and shamique Moore who
voices Miles Morales in into the
spider-verse across the spider-verse and
upcoming beyond the spider-verse says I
will say that this story tops the first
one if the sky was the limit last time
the sky is now the floor we're stepping
on it and looking at Jupiter so all
around it sounds like across the
spiderverse is going to be indeed better
than the first one which of course is
absolutely fantastic to hear it is going
to be really cool to explore a lot of
different Spider-Man universes which
we're going to get in this film so let
us know what you think about all of this
news in the comments down below and
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest Marvel news of course
you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof